desde hace unos días Los investigadores
se activan sobre el manejo por parte de
Donald Trump de información
gubernamental altamente confidencial a
principios de esta semana los abogados
del expresidente fueron vistos saliendo
del departamento de justicia y los
medios de comunicación informaron de que
estos han recibido una notificación de
que Trump es objeto de una investigación
penal se trata de una práctica habitual
permite a los abogados Defensores de
responder al Gran Jurado antes de una
acusación
con testimonios de Testigos y
grabaciones de audio al fiscal especial
Jack Smith ha estado examinando si Trump
ocultó a propósito documentos
clasificados que tenía en su casa de mar
a lago Trump debió entregarlos cuando
dejó el cargo y no lo hizo el año pasado
el FBI haya no su residencia de Florida
y encontró 13.000 documentos cientos de
ellos eran clasificados y algunos eran
top secrets
la redada se produjo meses después de
que los abogados de Trump aseguraran que
todos los archivos habían sido devueltos
en respuesta Trump negó que se le había
avisado que pronto podría ser imputado
por segunda vez
nadie me ha dicho que sería imputado y
no debería hacerlo porque no he hecho
nada malo el exmandatario afirma que es
víctima de un uso político del
departamento de justicia y del FBI y
señala que se han encontrado también
archivos clasificados en las residencias
y oficinas de Joe biden Y Mike pence
pero en ambos casos los expedientes
fueron entregados inmediatamente